let's bring in the ucla head coach chip
kelly who joins us on the program
coach how are you today i'm good
trying to figure out how to navigate the
next
six months here how are you planning on
doing that
well we have to get uh rulings from the
ncaa of what we're actually allowed to
do
um with our players since the season has
been postponed
so you know what can you do right now
our guys are just
lifting and running with our strength
and conditioning coach we haven't done
any on-field work
because we haven't actually been allowed
to by those
state and local authorities so we were a
little bit behind some of the other
schools you know you look at
network television and see other schools
practicing and we haven't been allowed
to do that yet so
we're trying to navigate and put a
schedule together of what the next uh
couple of months will look like how were
you told that the season was postponed
we had a meeting on monday night um with
all the coaches in the athletic
directors
and then with the medical um staff
the covid medical staff for the league
and they kind of gave us
a lot of statistics of what's going on
in in the pac-12 communities
um in terms of rates of covet in in the
areas that we live in
um then they talked a little bit about
uh the cardiac implications that they're
starting to learn about with covet
and then they talked about testing and
so that was monday
um tuesday there was going to be a
meeting on tuesday morning with the ceos
the presidents and the chancellors of
the university
and then they would vote on it on what
what was going to be the determination
of
when do we play um and then i would get
told around one o'clock on uh
tuesday afternoon um that there was
going to be a press release that we were
going to postpone the season
if it was a coach's vote how would that
have gone
to play football that's
um you know what i don't know if we
would have voted
after listening to the medical people
talk you know i think going into that
meeting
everybody was really gung-ho about
getting back with our players and
and understanding you know that there
are implications for code and everybody
knew it but i think
um after our meeting with the medical
people there were some
eye-opening things there at least for
myself that i was unaware of at the time
so
what stood out can you give me one of
those bullet points
yeah you know i think the increased
concern over the cardiovascular thing
when you look at eduardo rodriguez the
pitcher for the red sox who's out with
an inflamed heart
um the young man in indiana you know
feeney the offensive lineman
that had an incident they brought up
there was a pitcher in um
the tacoma area in washington a high
school kid uh 18 year old kid that died
um from covet in the springtime um and
that could have been part of it also um
so some of those things i think
there was also a basketball player that
played a florida state that was playing
overseas that passed away
um so they came you know that starts to
hit home a little bit when you're
starting to hear about
you know it's a little bit and the other
thing that we were made aware of is that
you could be asymptomatic and still have
heart issues and some of these heart
issues wouldn't be
um detected unless you had a cardiac mri
and those are a little bit different and
hard to get from a testing standpoint is
the way they explain it to us
how did you tell your team we had a zoom
meeting you know we're still not allowed
to meet with them with that many people
in person
so uh we got the news of one and then we
got everybody on a zoom call
at 1 30 and then our position coaches
called everybody individuals and we're
in the process of touching base with all
of our kids individually and then i was
down at workouts
um yesterday i'll be back down again
today to talk to him face to face
or mask the mask i should say yeah i'm
trying to understand this chip where
the information you have with the pac-12
how
is that different is it different than
what the acc or the sec or the big 12
have or the big 10 has
i would love these medical communities
to get together
and and maybe make it on a zoom call and
share their information like we should
understand this
i think to be fair to the sport student
athlete and really
to society what what is at stake here
and what are we finding out and why
aren't we cross-pollinating and sharing
that information
that's a great point you know i i don't
know how that community talks
um the other issue is that the
prevalence of cases
in the pac-12 communities is different
than the prevalence of cases in
nebraska so to speak so i think there's
there's also
there can't be a one-size-fit-all from
as i understand this
because it some areas have been infected
a lot more and other other areas aren't
as infected
you know so um i think that has to be
taken into consideration
there are different parts of the country
that aren't as infected as this and
that's
that's the deal and then the next step
becomes testing so
if you have a community that has a lot
of covert cases then your
testing is slower than places when
there's not a lot of
a lot of it that's why i don't think
there's a one size fit all
for some of these things and that's
where it gets frustrating when you look
at it overall and say
how come and we have to answer those
questions how come they can practice and
we can't practice
but there were times earlier when we
would send tests away but it would be
except take seven to ten days
um to get test results back and
understanding that is that
we're trying to get our asymptomatic
third string left guard tested
and there's people on ventilators that
need to get tested so there's a
you know there's a social uh
responsibility that goes along with it
too
when you're in a community that has a
lot of coving cases
has it hit you yet that you're not going
to be coaching football this fall
a little bit um but obviously it's not
all us i mean
women's soccer can't play you know i go
back to the spring
when we were sitting in a meeting in in
our basketball coaches you know corey
closing our women's basketball team was
getting ready to be a high ranked team
in the
ncaa tournament so they were affected
our baseball and softball teams were
affected in the springtime
um so it is football and that's our job
and that's our lives and that's what we
care about our players but
everybody's been effective at this um
mikey ann
who's a great sports media guy out here
in the pac-12 i just saw that he just
got released and uh
is not working because the pac-12
network isn't going to be broadcasting
games in the fall so
it's a little bit bigger and i think we
have to step back as individuals and say
poor me it's
it's there's a lot of people that have
have had uh
implications from this and and we
somehow have to get a handle on it
because it's
it's not just sports related it's
everything related and
um when you get a death toll over 160
000 in this country
you know sometimes when you say hey i
can't play football i
maybe there's some other things that are
a little bit more important than us
playing football right now
i know you hope to play football in the
spring do you expect
to play football in the spring you know
what that's a great
question then and i don't know if we can
um and i've said that you know can you
play two seasons
in in one calendar year and what is that
told um
our whole goal and everything we do in
our chancellor said it our north star
that guides us is the health and safety
of our players so
you know we better really look as from a
health and safety standpoint
say we have a vaccine can you actually
play a football season in the spring and
then come back and play a football
season in the fall
that's never been done but i think we
need to look into that part too
before we just say hey automatically
we're just going to play in the
springtime because
you know how safe is that and i don't
know that information and
when we get to situations where it's
medical and some of those things
i'm going to defer to the experts in
terms of what they they will tell us
because i don't i don't have the answers
in that situation
thank you coach um do we know if players
are going to be able to transfer
are you uh concerned if any of your
players would be able to go
and try to play some place this this
fall
yeah we haven't heard anything from the
ncaa they just made a ruling yesterday
about
eligibility you know you would retain
your eligibility if you opted out
or if you played in less than 50 of the
games um so that's the first ruling that
we've gotten i think
this is all new for everybody you know
as it came down with both the big ten
and the pac-12 and then you know i know
obviously we're the power five
conferences but you feel for the guys in
the mountain west and the mac
you know they they're done and then
people have already forgotten about the
ivy league and division two and division
three and
you know we're not the only ones that
have this but um the ncaa has
has to really come out quickly here with
a with some rulings for everybody
because um players have to make
decisions i don't know exactly what that
ruling is and
would kids be instantly eligible or not
instantly eligible
and um that's there's a lot of lot of
work to be done even though we're not
playing football but there's a lot of
work to be done especially
administratively
how about usc and ucla just have a
scrimmage in november
and we televise it you okay with that i
would love that and i think clay would
love that too
we we could put a bubble over the rose
bowl and
you could live up at the rose bowl for
uh
for a couple weeks so that we made sure
there was no covet and then
and then uh and then go play i think
that would be a great experience for
everybody
that'd be great uh coach good luck and
uh thanks for joining us thanks dan
appreciate it
that's uh chip kelly ucla head coach